the good funds attract
the good startups
and then
the good startups refer other good
startups
and eventually they go to the same fund
and it's like it's you know it's feeding
itself so right it's a little bit
intertwined
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20 minute leaders and welcome
aurelie gleek
overly joined vintage in 2016 before
joining vintage she worked for mckinsey
and company in belgium france and israel
in the fast growth tech division prior
to mckenzie ollie lived for 10 years in
california united states where she
worked for merrill lynch in wealth
management and private banking
only started her career as a mechanics
and electronics engineer for indigo an
israeli startup in the printing industry
that was later acquired by hp
ole has also managed and advised
technology startups
okay aurelie glick welcome to 20 minute
leaders how you doing
good how are you
i'm doing really really great thank you
very very much i'm i'm really excited to
have you here and this is actually the
first episode in almost 700 episodes and
that i'm going to be talking to somebody
in the fund of funds and i want to know
exactly what that means you're with
vintage investment partners soon
embarking on a new and exciting journey
and we'll touch on that transition a
little bit
but but i'd love to hear your story from
from you know the military
to
mckenzie to
vintage and looking at fast-growing
companies and investing in other funds
in the ecosystem so a lot a lot to
unpack in these 20 minutes um and so why
don't we just get started holy tell me a
little bit about yourself and a little
bit about your journey
oh wow um so i'm born and raised in
israel um did my army services you know
everybody has to go through here in
technology
um left the army service and started
working for um
basically being like the cable guy here
walking around the neighborhood and uh
fixing cables
um
literally fixing cables
yeah
fix it oh that's my serious sorry yeah
fixing really literally fixing going on
people's roofs and fixing uh cable tv
um
and then um
joined um indio
uh digital printing
as their service engineer and then
relocated with them uh to the
netherlands the headquarters was at
maastricht uh wonderful city right on
the border of uh belgium and germany uh
so basically uh went all around europe
fixed the machines uh drove everywhere
in europe was fantastic for a really
young uh uh a young age
fixed those machines um all over europe
and england as well and in australia as
well a little bit uh then ended up being
in the training center and training
engineers that came over so did a lot of
technology uh mechanics and electronics
and stuff like that
were you surrounded by a lot of other
female mechanics and a lot of other
female engineers that were sort of cable
girls
uh story of my life no always well
usually the only woman in the room
wow and and how and what was that
experience like already from a young age
and obviously today everybody's talking
about the fact that we want to empower
more female leaders in the tech world
but you know i imagine that back then it
wasn't necessarily the talk of the
street and it was so common right
yes so i'm i'm
a little old so it was but then it was
like very uh very rare um it was i think
that at that age i
was so audacious and with such young
chutzpah that
i felt like it was you know it was okay
it was normal and i was wondering it's
really weird that there are no other
women in the room like with me on on
this journey um as you know as i got
older i understood it was a little rare
um
but i didn't see it as different uh at
that time
uh yeah
interesting okay so the what was the
transition for you from you know being
an engineer to to the investment side of
things and mckinsey was in between right
so what was sort of that path for you
so um it's funny but indeed when i was
an engineer um i always had degrees in
my fingernails and i was sitting one day
and thinking hey you know what i've
never actually had a business training
and i want to get rid of all this grease
in my fingernails uh
let's get a real degree a white collar
degree and so after leaving
indigo i started studied at maastricht
university i did my bachelor's degree
there my master's and my mba
and
then did my dissertation
for uh mckinsey and company in the area
of uh biotechnology startup evaluation
biotechnology startup evaluation wow
yeah
that was awesome many years ago yeah
well it was when like the biotechnology
uh ecosystem started emerging from
israel and so that was really
interesting um
and then i moved i worked with mckinsey
for a few years
uh then i had my own company for a few
years
uh yeah then moved to the us and did
some other stuff there
so before we advance to what you were
doing some other stuff and and then
eventually leading to vintage um
you know writing a report like this and
doing a dissertation on you know a new
emerging technology or emerging you know
really ecosystem and domain within
within israel one that is going to
become extremely prominent not just from
the recent announcements we've seen of
recent biotech companies uh but really
in the last in the last decade or so
what is that sort of process for you how
do you go about you know familiarizing
yourself with this domain and coming up
with a strong you know thesis on what is
happening here and and how do we how do
we foresee what's going to happen
and your question is when i was back
then doing the dissertation or today
correct yeah well back then and then
we're gonna ask and then i'm gonna ask
you about today yeah yeah
well it's um the thesis was around the
emergence of an ecosystem so
and it's interesting if you look now um
you you can't imagine the israeli
ecosystem without automotive right tech
or without cyber tech but i mean people
forget that it's an evolution and it
takes years for an ecosystem to be built
um and so back then at the time it was
um
probably the uh the emergence of the
biotech ecosystem and so that was uh the
first uh things that we did was really
to understand what are the uh
common denominators of companies that
were successful and how do you uh value
them
okay that makes sense and so
transition to vintage i want to make
sure we have enough time to talk about
that
transition to vintage what today so i
mean today uh so vintage manages three
uh billion dollars uh today
um and uh basically investing in two
things in funds and in late stage
startups uh so the funds um it's
investing in israeli funds in european
funds and in u.s based funds
large funds or breakout funds we call
which is
funds that were started first-time funds
by experienced managers
and then late stage startups i would say
startups that are around
their round b or a little bit later it's
always co-investing with our funds uh
always coming together with the funds
that we're invested in
and uh and it could be a direct
investment and it could be um
[Music]
also a secondary so that's something
that emerged in the past few years not
on the primary basis but on a secondary
basis when management teams want a
little bit of liquidity
right now from your perspective
having spent so much time as an engineer
yourself as a technologist as a
researcher as a consultant is this the
was this you know sort of the the ideal
path or the most you know common
understanding you know if people around
you would they expect aurelie to then go
into either investing or specifically
into an a firm like vintage
um
i think that there's no right way um
it's investing
has many different disciplines in it
you can either come from
expertise in a certain domain and then
you are approaching it as an expert in
that domain
um you can come from a financial
background and bringing your
financial
experience and knowledge
it's
basically investment you know being an
investor is not for a particular
profile so it's pretty flexible so
actually you know and um i have a lot of
women approaching me and and asking how
does to be an investor how can i be a
part of it i'm never going to be an
investor
there's no one answer for it it's uh you
know i think everybody could bring their
own skills and experience to becoming an
investor
and your personal
transition inside what was that like so
you're moving you know farther and
farther from the you know in hebrew we
say from the medal from the barzelim so
literally you moved from the cable
towards you know the series b and and
fun stage you know on a very personal
level what what what is your experience
like as you're now about to deploy
capital and lots of capital into this
ecosystem and making those big decisions
i think that i feel like if i'm thinking
about my own experience and what what am
i bringing to the table as an investor
is basically bringing that complicated
set of experiences
and having been there and having been
interacted interacting with
tens of thousands of people in different
instances from technology to
different business transactions to
different industries
what i
brought to the table here
is
understanding of the business side of
experience understanding the incentives
of people understanding the markets
understanding trends
um but again this is my personal set of
experiences that i think that i'm uh you
know i brought to the table here
right and so as you're going around and
you know let's let's first start
talking about you know investing in
funds and then i'd like to understand a
little bit about your perspective on
late-stage companies
you know i'm i'm also in the investing
world and i and i see what it's like
investing in early-stage companies but
you know when you're pro when you're
thinking about investing in a fund what
does that actually mean what is a fund
of funds on a very basic level
sure so if you think about a fund um
on a 30 000 feet level
or a helicopter viewers we used to call
it at mckinsey it's the sum of wait wait
what's the what's the difference between
a helicopter view and a 30 000 feet
we have two helicopter pilots in the
company you should ask them but
but um
it's a fund it's basically the sum or
the aggregation of of all its startups
right right um so if you're thinking
about a fund um
basically look at the startups that uh
they invested in or the portfolio
companies and then you can find um you
know what what the fund is basically all
about um and this is really generalizing
right it's much much more than that and
it's about
the
many things like you know
the team
and the investment team and the
supporting team and the added services
that they bring into the table
and
their thesis and uh and so on and so on
so there's many many uh things that go
into it but basically on a general level
it's it's the portfolio companies at the
end of the day and their returns
and so as you're approaching as you're
talking to a fund you know how much of
that is the portfolio is the existing
portfolio comes because obviously once
you're investing they're going to
continue to invest in more portfolio
companies so how much of it is the
portfolio companies versus the
management
and and and you know sort of the synergy
between you and the managers or their
expertise
how does how does the distribution look
like
i think it's it's eventually intertwined
um
because eventually um you know it's very
strong the distribution here is not a
belt curve distribution it's a totally
different distribution in the vc world
okay and it's
it's interesting because the good funds
attract
the good startups
and then
the good startups refer other good
startups
and eventually they go to the same font
and it's like it's you know it's feeding
itself so right it's a little bit
intertwined
right and that makes a lot of sense and
and is that process sort of the due
diligence process on a fun is that in
any way similar to due diligence on a
startup you know are you looking at
similar matrix are you are you asking
similar questions because a fund is a
startup in some sense but it's also very
far from a startup
it's very interesting because you know
people think that a fund is a different
completely different uh species than a
startup but it did right um a fund has
to fundraise just like startups have to
fundraise yeah um
and there's a lot of challenges that are
similar but it's basically a business
and so um yeah absolutely agree it's uh
there there's a lot of similarities and
disrespect is
now you do have to
you know understand both because you're
doing both you're both investing in
funds but then you're also co-investing
sometimes in the late stage companies
and and
what does that process look like from
you you're you're now transitioning your
thought process you're going to meet a
late stage company you know what is your
what is your process like is your
because you have a lot of opportunities
to invest in late stage and obviously
don't take all of them you take only a
handful so what are sort of the defining
factors for you on those regards
so we're always investing alongside our
funds so it's always going to be
either that a fund refers as startups to
us and then we invest together or that
we refer startups to our funds
funds on our network
so it'll always be together
um
and then there's
you know due diligence just a normal due
diligence process that takes place you
know understanding the business
understanding the technology
uh meeting the team uh understanding the
landscape competitive landscape and so
on but it's always going to be together
with the funds in our network
right and so if you look back at these
five and a half years of investments and
you even go as far back and think about
you know from you know mechanics and
technology to mckinsey you know how do
you summarize sort of the where you're
at right now
in your career you're about to embark on
something new so if you stop for a
second and reflect on where you are
today you know what what what is going
through your mind
wow it's a big question um yeah i think
that um
personally i've never um
you know there's people that are experts
on one thing and they're 20 years in the
same thing or 30 years in the same thing
and then they're top experts in their
domain for for something very specific
i'm business experts i've done so many
different things from technology to
business from corporates to startups and
vice versa and so i think
um i look at myself as a business expert
i know what drives people i know um
what drives markets um i can see things
a little early um and i love i really
love
growing things and pushing things and
putting kpis and achieving them so i
think from my perspective
um
yeah doing business and running a
business is uh what's most exciting for
me
and so is when you're seeing the running
business and pushing the boundaries is
that
from a day-to-day management perspective
or is that on a high level
entrepreneurial perspective on the
impact that you're going to make on
users which part really excites you
about this
wow all of the above
it's it's really running the operations
and
running the teams
but also creating business impact but
also at this point in my life i'd like
to create like a little bit of a global
impact
uh and that's what i'm going to do in
the uh in the next endeavor it's going
to be something that will create a
global impact well i think that you know
when we talk about impact you've already
made quite quite a big impact almost
every day i hear about vintage and so
it's a i think that already there the
the a big impact has already been
obviously made on on many many portfolio
companies that you've invested in and
and that your funds have invested in and
and i want to take you back a little bit
a little while back even before the army
and i want to get to know you a little
bit better
and you know perhaps even all the way to
elementary school middle school if you
have to think you know
what made orally curious back then you
know what fascinated you on a day-to-day
basis well what what are some things
that come to mind
i was always dismantling everything
and everywhere like everything else
physically yes yeah just mapping
everything electronic like everything
around me that was electronic i would
open it apart and just put it together
so i was really really curious about
electronic stuff um also i
had a computer like the really first
computer like the commodore whatever it
was called
and there was no
internet back at the time i mean it and
and but i really was really um
fascinated by technology
and at the time again there were no
women around me or no girls basically
around me that talked about technology
and there was no internet so i couldn't
really go online and start you know like
like my son everything you know he's
programming he's doing ai programming
and everything he learned is from online
but so it was uh that was something that
fascinated me always technology
electronics computers programming
how far back do you think
you when when at what age do you think
you already had the conviction that this
is going to be your world that you're
going to go into technology you're going
to go into electronics and and that and
that you love it
i think always
when i when i was um
15 or 14 my mom said well you need a
profession and so
you have to study electricity so you can
uh do stuff like soldier stuff like that
so she sent me to a school called ort
and um i was the only again the only
girl in the classroom um and i studied
and i wanted a computer science right
but then i came one year too late and so
they tricked me and they said
there is a computer science with
electronics so you know the computer
signs you already uh missed that that's
for uh um when you were 15. so i said
okay electronics computers it's the same
that's fine and then apparently they
tricked me it was 90 electronics and 10
computers but um
yeah it's uh
actually i'm happy that they did it
if you look at
the five five and a half years i just
passed with vintage
you know obviously um there's a lot of
inspiration to be gained from working
with a lot of the portfolio companies
and on the impact that vintage makes you
know on this ecosystem but what what led
to your inspiration on a daily level so
you know you wake up every day you go to
work work really hard you know what
where is that source of inspiration
coming from
i think it's the impact when i see a
business really when i see business
impact i get really excited so
when we started the valued services for
example you know we were trying to find
kind of you know where is it the
good win-win for everybody and when we
found it we saw what works for everybody
um and we started putting kpis and we
put kpis as the pos and pocs that we
generate for companies
every time we had a po and poc
successful we literally we celebrated it
so i think that when there is a business
impact and we can make a change that
gets me really excited and inspires me
i love it orally thank you very very
much for spending this time with me i
really appreciate it
and i loved hearing about your journey
all the way from being the cable girl to
mckinsey to your own company and to
now
vintage and now
going back to entrepreneurship i think
that's just awesome and i can't wait to
hear about what you do and thank you
very very much for the time and
inspiration and stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you you too thanks for having me
thank you
you